bonjour nous sommes en direct ce
mercredi matin pour faire un nouveau
point de situation sur ce qu'il se passe
en Ukraine je suis avec Alexis vers
chaque journal adjoint au pôle et
adjoice
désolé pour ce petit début un peu raté
merci à vous en tout cas d'être présent
avec nous on va vous montrer hop voilà
cette carte sur laquelle on va s'appuyer
comme d'habitude tout au long de ce live
on fait souvent ces petits points de
situation et là il y a du nouveau ça
bouge donc on va en parler on va
peut-être d'abord parler de ce qui s'est
passé hier ces référendum dans les
quatre oblast qu'on voit sur cette carte
l'ougance louance que dont le don-basse
ça pourrait-je dire et Carson c'est
référendum largement remporté par les
prorus est-ce que ils ont une valeur
c'est-à-dire un homme Alexis non ils
n'ont pas de de valeur ils seront pas
reconnus internationalement ils sont pas
reconnus par par l'Ukraine voilà ils
sont reconnus par la Russie les
résultats étaient connus d'avance et
parfois on peut imaginer il y a un droit
des à disposer de même c'est un principe
de droit international donc il y a il y
a des règles qui peuvent encadrer le
fait qu'un territoire
quitte un autre pour devenir indépendant
ou pour rejoindre un pays mais disons
qu'il y a des il y a des règles des
procédures formelles qui s'appliquent
pour pour qu'un tel résultat un tel
processus soit valable et en
l'occurrence c'est pas le cas c'est
encore moins le cas si vous voulez de
manière encore plus spectaculaire que
qu'avec la Crimée parce que qu'est-ce
qui s'était passé en 2014 en 2014 si
vous voulez il y avait déjà des
militaires russes en crimés puisqu'il y
avait la grande base navale de de
Sébastopol et si vous voulez il y a eu
aucun combat il y a eu les petits hommes
verts de de Poutine qui était là qu'on
m'aime pas tiré un coup de feu etc et
puis il y a eu au moins formellement ça
ressemblait à peu près à quelque chose
on va dire
et ça s'est passé entre
pacifiquement et puis il y a eu une
d'abord une indépendance de la Crimée
puis une demande des nouvelles autorités
entre guillemets Crimée pour être
attaché à la à la Fédération de Russie
là en fait ce qui n'est n'est pas
crédible c'est déjà le le tempo là la
chronologie cirque en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé le l'objectif officiel des
Russes l'objectif militaire
dans l'est de l'Ukraine c'était de
prendre militairement
l'intégralité notamment des deux au
blases de Lougansk et de nièces qui
forment ce qu'on appelle la région du
Dombas et où il y a déjà deux
républiques séparatistes qui existent
officiellement depuis 2014
c'était d'en finir militairement on va
dire et ensuite d'organiser un processus
politique qui devait qui devait se
passer en septembre qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé fin août les Ukrainiens lance une
contre-offensive
dans la région et ils reprennent vous
voyez en bleu les territoires russes de
la région de carquis et qui en fait
réservé de zone de défense à
l'ougance et à Donia c'est par ailleurs
les Russes n'avancent pas n'arrivent pas
à avancer à Donia est-ce qu'on le voit
la carte militaire de ce point de vue là
et la même depuis je grossis le trait
mais elle est quasiment la même depuis
des mois donc les Russes sont dit bah on
peut pas on n'a pas fini militairement
de de réunir entre guillemets ces deux
oblast et donc on va repousser les
référendums et donc fin août début
septembre les Russes sont tout
simplement annulés les référendum qui
devait avoir lieu et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que l'offensive la contrepensive
ukrainienne était tellement puissante et
rapide à cariffe que les Russes ont été
prises cours ils se sont dit puisque
militairement on perd pied on va en fait
se servir des référendum pour pour faire
une sorte de de d'actes politiques pour
dire ben voilà maintenant quoi que vous
fassiez quoi que
effondré mais malgré tous les les Russes
sont en difficulté parce que notamment
il n'y a plus de ponts et donc pour
recompléter les les les troupes pour
acheminer la logistique etc les Russes
sont en difficulté donc qui se disent
que finalement les référendums ne vont
pas acter une nouvelle situation
militaire mais deviennent un outil pour
compenser ce qui est quand même une
défaite militaires de la Russie de de
depuis un mois et donc ça c'est l'autre
problème c'est que c'est un homme ne
résolve pas le problème militaire qui
est que la Russie est en difficulté face
aux Ukrainiens vont y revenir et donc la
décision prise par Vladimir Poutine de
conserve avec ses avec ses référendum et
bien c'est la mobilisation partielle à
hauteur de 300 000 réservistes pour
essayer de changer la donne militaire
sur le terrain mais on va voir c'est
c'est très loin d'être gagné pour pour
la Russie mais la transition est
parfaite alors je vais juste vous
expliquer parce que sur la carte vous
voyez des petits pourcentages au niveau
des différentes et vous voyez en haut
voilà c'est la part de l’oblas contrôlé
par les Russes donc par exemple louante
vous avez 99 50 abrisia 72 personnes 93
voilà c'est pour ça que on voulait vous
expliquer quand même ce que c'était
c'est petit pourcentage que vous voyez
sur cette carte alors juste du coup je
fais une petite remarque mais mais là on
le voit bien les Russes de contrôle pas
l'intégralité de de ces quatre blastes
qui sont visés par ces référendum et
d'ailleurs il y a un doute on ne sait
pas très bien si ces référendum
concerne les territoires contrôlés par
la Russie ou l'intégralité des
territoires de ces Oblats de ces régions
administratives ukrainiennes on imagine
que ils peuvent ils ne peuvent pas
organiser des référendum là où ils n'ont
pas le contrôle et le problème c'est que
c'est la question du référendum quelle
est la quelle est l'étendue quelle est
l'assiette de référendum et il
semblerait par exemple que pour le blast
de Denis mais
franchement on a plein de de chercheurs
différents on arrive pas très bien
savoir mais par exemple à doniak il
semblerait que le référendum portait sur
l'intégralité le black de données à sec
d'accord alors que il ne comprenait pas
alors allougon c'est plus facile parce
qu'il contrôle quasiment 100% de
lougance sauf que on va le voir tout à
l'heure les Ukrainiens sont à
l'offensive
dans un coin de lougans ce qui est déjà
ils ont commencé à perdre quelques
territoires donc c'est une vraie
question c'est à l'issue de ces
référendum où s'arrêtera entre
guillemets la nouvelle frontière russe
et sera des implications militaires
dernier petit point parce que sur ces
quatre places pour vous donner comme des
ordres de grandeur j'ai sorti ma
calculette c'est quatre Oblats c'est
108000 km². là-dessus la Russie on
contrôle actuellement on va dire allez
au max et par ailleurs il faut ajouter à
cela la Crimée c'est 27000 km². donc ça
fait un tout si vous voulez d'environ
130 000
kilomètres carrés donc c'est un pays
comme la Grèce voilà comme ça on a des
ordres de grandeur et c'est 20% en gros
de la taille de l'Ukraine rappelle
toujours que l'Ukraine c'est plus grand
que la France 600 000 km², effectivement
c'est toujours bon de le savoir je salue
simpliste qui nous rejoint VLF très
heureux qui est très zone de retrouver
nous aussi on est très heureux un fidèle
de de de ce format Moula et qui nous
rejoint vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions et justement on a Jason Riolo
qui nous demande comment la mobilisation
partielle peut avoir déjà un impact ne
faut-il pas du temps pour déplacer les
troupes et les équiper mais c'est tout
l'enjeu
au jour enfin je J0 la mobilisation n'a
aucun impact
il faut plusieurs semaines pour
commencer à avoir des troupes qui vont
être envoyés sur le front parce que les
troupes il faut d'abord les réunir et et
on a vu que la la mobilisation en
elle-même en Russie ne se passe pas
extrêmement bien ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose il faut les
organiser en unité donc ensuite il faut
les il faut les structurer il faut avoir
les équipements qui vont avec les
équipements c'est des camions des
blindés des chars des fusils des de
l'artillerie enfin tout ce qui fait une
armée moderne et par ailleurs il est il
faut les former alors sur la formation
on peut trouver un équilibre on peut
dire tant pis on les forme extrêmement
rapidement de semaine et on les envoie
sur le front pour un résultat qui sera
probablement très mauvais mais mais
sinon il faut prendre deux de moi trois
mois pour les former et là peut-être que
le résultat sera meilleur mais ça ça
nous projette au mois de janvier par
exemple
or là il y a il y a un problème immédiat
pour l'armée c'est comment elle fait
pour tenir
face aux Ukrainiens qui continuent on va
y reparler mais l'offensive ukrainienne
celle de carquif aujourd'hui elle
continue elle s'est largement arrêtée
c'est que la frontière s'est figée mais
malgré tout elle continue et quand on
zoomera sur la carte on verra qu'il y a
un vrai danger pour les Russes donc
maintenant sont-ils capables de tenir
leur ligne
on va dire pendant un mois
un gros mois le temps que les les
réservistes appelés sur le front arrive
bah c'est un c'est vraiment une gageure
pour le Kremlin il y a Florent qui
Florian qui nous demande bonjour c'est
ton pourquoi l'armée ukrainienne s'est
arrêtée dans leur fugace contre-attaque
dans l'Est justement alors c'est ça
c'est très c'est très intéressant alors
déjà première chose il faut savoir que
tout offensive finit par s'arrêter parce
qu'il y a une sorte de point culminant
qui fait que plus vous avancez plus vos
lignes s'étendent plus votre rôle se
disperse
au bout d'un moment il faudrait venir
donc si vous voulez il y a il y a
toujours un point haut à une offensive
par ailleurs ce qu'on avait dit la
dernière fois je l'avais dit aux
conditionnel parce que c'était juste
après mais il semblerait que ce soit
quand même bien le bien le cas si vous
voulez les Russes n'ont pas cherché à
résister à carquif ça ne ça ne minimise
pas la victoire ukrainienne mais sur
cette constater que les les Russes se
sont repliées il y a eu quasiment pas de
combat
quasiment pas eu de combat en tout cas
dans l'ouest de confiance que au début
on verra que les combats maintenant sont
sont très puissants mais si vous voulez
les les Russes en fait on décidait de se
replier au niveau de la ligne de front
actuel qui se fait une rivière qui
s'appelle la rivière au ski et
maintenant en revanche pour le coup il
tienne enfin plutôt plus précisément ils
essayent de tenir et on va voir qu'il y
a deux têtes de pont il y a deux
endroits où les Ukrainiens ont réussi à
franchir la rivière justement coupant à
l'ouest et l'imam au sud et ça pour les
Russes c'est extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'ils ont
établi nouvelle une nouvelle ligne de
front une nouvelle de nouvelle
fortifications mais qui sont pour le
coup extrêmement proches on le voit là
sur la carte de des frontières de le
place de l'ougance et donc si les
Ukrainiens parviennent à enfoncer ces
nouvelles lignes de défense russe c'est
à dire que les les
Ukrainiens pourraient
comme russe au regard du droit russe et
donc ça pose des tas de questions et
notamment celle de l'usage du nucléaire
tactique mais bon c'est un autre sujet
on en reparlera tout à l'heure on en
reparlera effectivement Mozart databaïs
qui nous dit non seulement les nouvelles
troupe sont mal équipées mais en plus
pas ou peu formé ça va être une
véritable boucherie c'est ce qu'on dit
tout à l'heure il faut équiper ses
nouvelles troupes absolument alors en
fait comment pourrait résumer le la
chose si vous voulez l'armée russe
c'est un budget officiellement de 80 à
90 milliards de dollars par an en
réalité pour tout un tas de raisons
techniques c'est un peu plus mais donc
c'est par exemple beaucoup plus que le
que la France mais si vous voulez c'est
incomparable avec un budget avec le
budget militaire américain ou même par
rapport au budget de de le temps dans
son de son ensemble donc si vous voulez
l'armée russe l'armée conventionnelle je
parle pas de la des forces nucléaires ou
là il y a une parité avec les États-Unis
mais les forces conventionnelles l'armée
russe n'est pas une superpuissance
militaire et donc qu'est-ce qu'on a vu
depuis la réforme entamée en 2008 dans
les forces armées russes c'est qu'en
fait on a un modèle mixte de de de
conscrit
d'appeler mais qui tend à se réduire et
puis il y a un noyau de plus en plus
important de de soldats professionnels
d'armée professionnelle comme comme on
enfance et nous on a une sorte de
pyramide
la pointe de la pyramide ce sont des
armements qui en tout cas sur le papier
était annoncé comme extrêmement moderne
extrêmement performant d'ores et déjà
ces forces professionnelles qu'on a vu
se battre depuis maintenant plus de six
mois en Ukraine on a vu que c'est pas un
résultat absolument fameux et par
ailleurs comme il doivent tenir dans le
temps on descend la pyramide c'est que
maintenant les armements modernes
une bonne partie ont été détruits
capturés etc et donc par exemple le char
russe le plus moderne hormis l'armataque
et un service c'est le t90m le tech 90m
les Russes sont non à peu près 200 c'est
à dire autant que les Français ont des
chiens Leclerc mais en revanche ils
n'ont pas que ça ils ont une sorte de
profondeur de stock qui vient de l'Union
soviétique tout simplement mais donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu qu'est-ce qu'on a
vu en Ukraine ben on a vu là depuis
quelques mois des chartes et 62 m des
chartés 62m se dire que c'est des charts
des années 60-70 c'est déjà qu'on plus
de 50 ans aujourd'hui si c'était des
voitures ils ont une carte grise
collection enfin je je j'exagère à peine
mais c'est
donc voilà c'est si vous voulez c'est
transaction 61 c'est absolument je me
suis pas trompé et donc si vous voulez
les Russes aujourd'hui on un matériel
qui est de moins en moins moderne et
donc il faut qu'ils arrivent à conserver
une armée propre professionnelle très
bien équipé qui servent de un peu de
pointe de l'épée et en même temps qu'ils
arrivent à avoir cette masse
qu'aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui ne
dispose pas parce que la réalité des
chiffres aujourd'hui des ans de grandeur
c'est qu'il y a plus de d'ukrainien sur
le fond que dans un rapport probablement
de 1 à 2 je veux pas donner de chiffre
précis parce qu'on ne les a pas mais on
sait qu'à peu près 150000 russes sur le
front
ukrainien et on imagine qu'il y a il y a
probablement oui 300400
000 soldats
Ukrainiens donc en général quand on
invaye un pays quand on est à
l'offensive c'est l'inverse c'est
l'offenseur qui doit avoir plus de
troupes que que le français voilà alors
on pas mal de questions on va essayer de
vous répondre à tous hein promis parce
que c'est vous qui posez les questions
on essaie d'y répondre au mieux comme
d'habitude Joe cost il nous demande quel
impact sur l'Europe et le monde en cas
d'attaque sur l'Ukraine d'armes
nucléaire même de faible intensité de la
part des Russes alors là on va faire un
petit point
nucléaire
la première chose c'est que c'est un
sujet qui fait très peur c'est un sujet
qui déchaîne les fantasmes etc et donc
je sais pas comment dire mais il faut
essayer de rester rationnel proche des
faits etc qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
risque d'utilisation nucléaire personne
ne peut lier et là on parle encore une
fois de nucléaire tactique c'est-à-dire
un nucléaire entre guillemets de faible
intensité qui est destinée à être
employé sur le champ de bataille ça
s'oppose aux armements stratégiques qui
eux sont beaucoup plus puissants et qui
globalement
régulent la relation de dysphésion qui
existe entre les grandes puissances
nucléaires dans le monde voilà donc on
parle pas de ça on parle du nucléaire
tactique alors le nucléaire tactique
pour donner des ordres d'idées c'est
quand même très souvent aujourd'hui suis
plus gros quiiroshima ou négati donc on
sait pas non plus des choses
anodines je veux dire
allez vers le nucléaire tactique c'est
quand même déjà franchir un seuil
absolument considérable et qui n'a été
qui n'a pas été franchi depuis Hiroshima
et
ceci étant dit je donnerais une anecdote
d'une source bien placée au sein de
l'État que j'ai eu pour écrire un
article là-dessus il m'a dit je ne pense
pas que les Russes utiliseront le
nucléaire tactique et il s'est repris
après juste après en me disant oui mais
en même temps je pensais que les Russes
n'en varient pas n'en veilleraient pas
l'Ukraine donc voilà ce qui était à la
fois très honnête très prudent et voilà
où on en est si vous voulez maintenant
ceci étant dit il y a une sorte de
rhétorique russe et occidentale qui se
met en oeuvre mais qu'on voit depuis le
24 février en matière nucléaire avec des
en place plus ou moins explicites
ça si vous voulez le premier niveau de
lecture c'est que ça fait très peur et
on se dit demain tel vide avec etc la
réalité c'est qu'il y a une il y a une
grammaire queifiée la dissuasion
nucléaire
et pour l'instant on n'en sort pas on la
respecte et surtout on a l'habitude ça
fait depuis la guerre froide que les
Russes et les
Occidentaux la manille donc pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de de dérapage je
vais prendre un exemple parce que les
Russes ont une doctrine nucléaire qui
donne les cas où la Russie pourrait
faire usage de l'un nucléaire il y a des
cas extrêmement classique c'est si
jamais il y a un missile
intercontinental qui qui a observé par
les Russes et qui arrive vers la Russie
donc là ils peuvent frapper s'il y a un
usage direct d'armes nucléaire ou
d'armes de destruction massive il y a un
troisième cas c'est si jamais il y a des
infrastructures absolument vitales
qui sont frappés par l'ennemi on peut
imaginer je sais pas qui frappe le
Kremlin ou que sais-je et il y a un
quatrième qui a beaucoup plus général
qui est le cas qui interroge aujourd'hui
c'est que l'armée la Russie pourrait
faire usage de nucléaire si jamais
l'existence de l'État
est mise en
danger si vous voulez bon après la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière la notion d'existence de l'État
oui parce que c'est référendum
on peut pas considérer que le fait de
grappiller quelques parts du territoire
russe mais en danger les tarifs mais on
ne connaît pas exactement la définition
que l'État russe va donner de l'Etat
russe voilà donc il y a un doute
là-dessus ce qu'on remarquera néanmoins
c'est que par exemple par exemple mettre
VDF donc elle est aujourd'hui le donc
l'ancien président russe qui aujourd'hui
le vice-président du Conseil de sécurité
russe qui parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
dans sa rhétorique il est même
clairement à la droite de Poutine il
fait l'Inno la surenchères par rapport
à Poutine mais dedef a rappelé de
manière extrêmement vive et qui pourrait
y avoir une utilisation du nucléaire
mais sauf que quand on regarde dans le
texte il ne fait que lire
la doctrine russe telle qu'on la connaît
depuis 20 ans tel que Poutine l'a
rappelé en février dernier et donc ça
c'est assez rassurant et par exemple il
l'a redit l'expression de d'existence
enfin de menace sur l'existence de
l'Etat russe et il n'a pas parlé par
exemple
d'intégrité territoriale de la Russie
parce que là si la Russie commençait à
dire attention notre ligne rouge
peut-être que ça pourrait être
l'intégrité territoriale là ils enverrai
un signal très clair en tout cas
beaucoup plus clair qui serait voilà
maintenant si vous continuez d'avancer
dans ce que nous considérons avec le
terrain territoire russe là pour le coup
on pourrait réagir mais pour l'instant
on n'en est pas là
maintenant
c'est c'est
qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer côté
européen si ils utilisent alors pareil
il faut rappeler que l'Ukraine n'est pas
dans le temps donc et l'Ukraine n'est
pas protégé par le parapluie nucléaire
américain ni par le parapluie
un éventuel parapluie français ou
britannique ça c'est la première chose
donc on imagine mal une escalade
nucléaire de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs les Américains l'ont
plus ou moins dit que la réponse
américaine un usage du nucléaire
tactique au Ukraine ne serait pas
parallèle de ce point de vue là
maintenant ceci étant dit on peut
imaginer beaucoup de réactions
occidentales qui ferait d'ailleurs que
l'usage du nucléaire pour Poutine serait
ainsi rationnelle d'un point de vue
militaire
il faut bien dire bien rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui les fournitures de
d'armement
occidentaux à l'Ukraine sont importants
indubitablement on a vu des des
équipements qui deviennent un peu il y a
mythiques ou idéal typique on peut
penser aux highmars les highmars donc
ils sont des pièces d'artillerie des
lance-roquettes multiples ça déporté de
80 km c'est pas non plus extraordinaire
ça met difficulté des Russes mais c'est
pas extraordinaire les occidentaux pour
l'instant ce sont refusés à fournir
on va dire des armes à longue portée ça
pourrait être très clairement s'il y
avait une attaque nucléaire
russe en Ukraine on peut imaginer que
les Occidentaux franchissent le cap les
Américains pourraient fournir des
missiles tomahaut que d'autres types de
missiles des drones d'attaque le royaume
d'action que sais-je tout un tas de
d'armements qui pourraient mettre un
mâle le dispositif russe dont la
profondeur ce qui est déjà un peu le cas
aujourd'hui mais ça pourrait être bien
pire si c'était sur des centaines de
kilomètres et non pas sur des dizaines
par ailleurs bon les sanctions seraient
encore élargi mais c'est pas le
principal l'autre chose c'est qu'on peut
imaginer que toute cette partie de la
planète qui est quand même une énorme
partie de la planète on va dire tout le
sud le sud au sens général l'un de la
Chine etc qui jusqu'à présent n'ont pas
condamné venir Poutine et grosso modo
ils ont dit écoutez c'est une guerre
européenne ça ne nous concerne pas
une sorte de de réserve poly et distante
on peut imaginer que la Chine est l'Inde
n'apprécie pas pour le coup
l'éventualité d'une escale nucléaire et
donc ça on voit Poutine aurait
finalement beaucoup à perdre et on voit
pas très bien ce qu'il aurait à gagner
sauf à faire peur du crédit en disant
bah vous voyez maintenant vous n'avancez
plus on avait élève justement qui nous
dit le retrait du soutien discret de la
Chine et de l'Inde vis-à-vis de la
Russie peut-elle faire changer les
choses alors l'addition des révoltes
russes qu'on a obligation annoncée ça on
va en parler peut-être un peu plus tard
mais en tout cas voilà avec la Chine et
la et l'Inde la poutine avait un allié
peut-être extrêmement prudent sur ce
retrait du soutien chinois ou indien il
y avait Antoine Bondaz cherchera la CRS
qui s'exprimer récemment à ce propos
parce que il y a quelques jours si j'ai
une Ping a appelé de manière assez ferme
à la paix c'est le feu etc la réalité
c'est qu'il dit il dit ça depuis 24
février et que de même ce que je vous
disais le discours nucléaire russe n'a
pas changé depuis le 24 février en
réalité pour l'instant au moins
officiellement le discours chinois et
Indien à l'endroit de la guerre entraîne
n'a pas foncièrement changé alors on a
late qui nous nous pose sur notre sujet
que le nucléaire qui nous demande quel
impact des drones iraniens sur lesquels
l'impact pardon des drones iranien sur
les combats qu'elle vient de la quantité
chez les Russes alors c'est quoi cette
histoire de drone je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez mais on a énormément parlé
des dons turques qui ont beaucoup
sérieuses Ukraine qui ont beaucoup servi
c'était les bailleurs TB2 et qui si vous
voulez c'est
ce qui est assez malin de la part des
Turcs c'est qu'ils ont investi un
créneau que les Européens et les le
moindre mesure les Américains ont
complètement délaissé ça des des drones
un peu low cost mais assez efficace
c'est une forme de de rusticité
technologique qui permet d'avoir plein
de drones et voilà
et donc les Ukrainiens comme les azéri
comme
voilà on au moment de la guerre avec la
la l'Arménie au carambar ont énormément
utilisé de drones et on s'est rendu
compte que c'était extrêmement
extrêmement efficace
et les Russes historiquement ont
toujours eu un certain retard en matière
de drone
or il y a un allié de la Russie qui
parce que parce qu'il n'a pas d'aviation
à au contraire investi les drones c'est
l'Iran
l'Iran on a pas d'aviation et donc
pourquoi penser cette ce manque ça fait
des années qu'elle met au point des
drones qui ont parfois des très longs
rayons d'action
on parle de 1000 1500 km voire plus je
sais et notamment qui ont été mises en
oeuvre au Yémen la guerre avec les
outils etc et je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais il y a quelques années
maintenant je veux pas dire de bêtises
mais non souvenir c'était 2019 il y
avait une
station pétrolière en Arabie Saoudite
qui va qui avait été tapé
probablement par des drones iraniens
alors depuis Yémen ou depuis l'Iran
c'est pas très bien mais ça veut dire
que les Iraniens c'est vraiment quelque
chose de difficile des attaques à longue
et qui soit en même temps extrêmement
précises on s'était rendu compte que les
iraniens avaient un vrai savoir-faire en
la matière ce qui s'est passé c'est que
là les Russes se rend compte qu'ils ont
un manque en matière de drone qui
commence à voir des difficultés
d'approvisionnement pour leur missiles à
l'emporter et que par ailleurs ils ont
du mal à
frapper le dispositif
ukrainien dans la profondeur parce que
les Ukrainiens se sont adaptés ils ont
un peu dispatché leur le leur force leur
logistique et donc voilà et et
visiblement il y a eu donc un
impact qui a été passé entre l'Iran et
la Russie l'Iran fournit des drones à la
Russie et surtout la Russie fabrique
chez elle des drones iraniens alors il y
a deux types de neurones il y a le chat
de 136 qui a un drone suicide les drones
suscitent c'est
[Musique]
sur leur cible et
qui visiblement en tout cas c'est les
premiers retours
qu'on a on a pu le voir dans la presse
anglo-saxonne notamment les Ukrainiens
sont quand même un peu inquiets de de
l'emploi de ces drone ça fait ça fait
deux semaines qu'on les voit vraiment en
action alors la DCA
ukrainienne a réussi en a bas de
certains il y a d'autres drones un peu
plus gros c'est les mots à Gers 6 et qui
sont des drones plus classiques de
reconnaissance de aussi de frappe mais
mais si oui c'est pas des drones
suicides
et donc les Ukrainiens sont en tout cas
on fait part de leur de leur inquiétude
et les Russes comptent beaucoup dessus
après c'est exactement comme pour les
armements
occidentaux qui avaient été fournis à
l'Ukraine il y a pas d'armes miracle
il y a une arme en tant que tel n'est
pas un Game changer
ce qui peut changer la donne c'est une
armée c'est un système c'est c'est pas
dans le point du système qui qui change
tout donc non ça va pas changer ça va ça
va pas retourner le le cours de la
guerre mais disons que ça fait ça fait
partie des atouts à venir de la Russie
pour essayer avec la mobilisation
générale par ailleurs partielle pardon
de d'essayer de
renverser la vapeur mais on est loin
pour l'instant alors une autre chose
qu'on a pas mal vu sur tout hier dans
l'actualité c'est Nord Stream 1 et 2 ces
images alors je vais je vais vous les
montrer dans quelques instants ces
images hop attendez hop on va faire
comme ça et on va vous montrer ces
images ici de North stream 2 voilà hop
c'est des images qu'on a vu voilà vous
pouvez les voir sur cette image là c'est
fuite on a observé ça en verbatique
est-ce qu'on sait ce qui s'est passé non
pour l'instant ce qu'on sait c'est que
ça peut pas être déjà est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer ce que c'est North stream
alors pardon alors stream 1 c'est le
gazoduc qui depuis
années fournissez l'Europe en gaz depuis
la Russie jusqu'à l'Allemagne donc en
passant par la mer par la mer baldique
et je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
mais il y avait un projet de doubler nos
streams pour augmenter les flux gaziers
et ça c'est une en stream 2 Nord Stream
2 qui aurait pu être mis en service
quasiment au lancement de l'opération
militaire spéciale russe en Ukraine et
finalement les les Allemands pas de bons
gré mais enfin ils ont suspendu le
projet Nord Stream 2 par ailleurs le
projet Nord Stream 1 il faut savoir que
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
depuis la fin de l'été enfin la fin de
l'été
plus vraiment opérationnelle parce qu'il
y avait d'après les Russes des problèmes
techniques la réalité c'est qu'il y a un
bras de fer
géopolitique et énergétique sur la
question du du gaz mais en tout cas ça
n'a pas de de changement on va dire
immédiat parce que ces deux gazoduc
plus de gaz ce qui d'ailleurs est le
troisième gaz de duc
Quibre l'Europe depuis la Russie il est
il passe par l'Ukraine c'est ça qui est
assez paradoxal puisque les flux de gaz
de la Russie jusqu'à l'Europe en passant
par l'Ukraine malgré la guerre ne se
sont jamais arrêtés et les Ukrainiens
continuent d'ailleurs de toucher des
droites de des droits de passage sur sur
ce gaz donc voilà hier il y a eu des des
fuites qui ont été importantes qui ont
été observées à la fois au niveau de
North streamer stream 2 ce qui a priori
exclut la possibilité d'un accident un
accident simultané à plusieurs endroits
plusieurs endroits mais parce qu'en fait
il y a trois endroits à 3 endroits en
même temps
c'est peu crédible
et par ailleurs on a des détonations
étaient ont été entendus maintenant donc
un acte de sabotage
[Musique]
qui serait déployé depuis un sous-marin
vous savez les nageurs de combat peuvent
passer par les tubes en stories des
sous-marins où il faut des sous-marins
miniatures qui qui sont spécialisés
là-dedans mais le problème c'est qu'un
sous-marin miniature généralement il y a
un navire mère qui le qui le guide
donc voilà pour l'instant on n'a pas
tellement de de
d'éléments ce qui est sûr c'est que il y
a des puissances
occidentales qui sur le papier en sont
capables à commencer par les Américains
ce qui est sûr aussi c'est que les
Russes sur le papier
ont cette capacité puisqu'ils ils ont
fait une ils se sont fait une spécialité
de ce qu'ils appellent les sous-marins
de mission spéciale qui sont
mises en œuvre d'ailleurs par une
direction spéciale qui qui dépend
directement de
[Musique]
président du russe et non pas du
ministère de la Défense qui s'appelle le
goji les recherches en eau profondes et
donc elle s'est sous-marins très
étonnant qui en fait déploie des
sous-marins plus petits qui sont sous le
sous la coque d'accord donc un
sous-marin mais un sous-marin fille
entre guillemets on peut envoyer de son
nucléaire et voilà sauf que les navires
de la du gugis sont dans la Flotte du
Nord c'est-à-dire en plus un heure près
du cercle arctique Mormant etc et en mer
Baltique a priori il n'y en a pas mais
bon voilà on en saura peut-être plus
dans et qu'elle peut être on nous
demande du coup qu'elle peut être la
répercussions pour l'économie en Union
Européenne
les répercussions et pour l'instant
c'est ce que je vous dis ça en tout cas
dans l'immédiat ça n'a pas d'impact à
très court terme puisque toute manière
Nord Stream 1 ou Nord Stream 2
n'abreuvez pas l'Europe maintenant c'est
le problème plus général de dans quel
état sera l'économie européenne sans
s'engageuses et à quelle échéance et
comment va-t-on passer l'hiver
on a liké qui nous demandait le quel est
le plus gros site de stockage de gaz en
Europe aucune idée voilà alors là mais
vous pouvez retrouver sûrement cette
information sur le bureau Alexis ne sait
pas tout non plus mais vous pouvez
continuer à poser des questions alors on
parlait tout à l'heure des tensions
internes de la de la Russie parce qu'il
y a eu de la mobilisation on a vu depuis
le début de la mobilisation il y a quand
même des incidents il y a des incidents
qui ce qui se passe est-ce que Poutine
est en train avec cette ovulation de se
fragiliser bah c'est un vrai risque si
vous voulez le ce qui s'est passé qui
était très étonnant un dernier mois que
nous rapporter des gens qui pouvaient
habiter en Russie à Moscou c'est que
finalement ils étaient extrêmement loin
de la guerre
contrairement aux Ukrainiens qui étaient
en plein dedans mais mais les Russes à
Moscou ils continuaient à vivre leur vie
j'ai envie de dire quasiment
comme à la normale la seule différence
c'est que vous aviez une inflation sur
certains produits un peu plus forte que
d'habitude des effets sur les sanctions
mais l'esprit n'était pas à la guerre et
finalement les les Russes regardez cette
opération militaire spéciale
c'est pas trop mais avec une forme de
lassitude une forme de
de lassitude si vous voulez et là tout
d'un coup c'est la guerre qui est rentré
dans les dans les foyers de quasiment
tous les Russes parce que voilà on parle
de 300 000 ça pourrait être plus ça
pourrait être plus même en Russie là je
parle de source russe qui évoque la
possibilité que ce soit en fait pas
300000 mais un million voire un million
2 alors peut-être qu'ils disent un
million un million 2 pour ratifier large
à la fin pour avoir 300000 possible mais
malgré tout c'est un choc pour les
Russes si vous voulez la la guerre
devient beaucoup plus réelle pour pour
eux
et donc évidemment ça ça pose des
questions pour le
pour le gouvernement de Vladimir Poutine
d'autant que c'est une mobilisation qui
acte quand même une défaite militaire
oui parce que jusque là venir Poutine
expliquer que la Russie faisait une
opération spéciale pour la déconnexion
entre les deux qui et là maintenant on
est on se mobilise pour parce que là on
perd du terrain il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose et la solution c'est la
mobilisation absolument il y a une sorte
de décoration complète entre les moyens
qui ont été mis en œuvre au début on l'a
dit redit mais 150.000 200000 hommes
c'est rien pour pour prendre un pays
comme l'Ukraine quand les Allemands sont
arrivés en France et les 2 millions de
soldats allemands qui sont contraser la
frontière
donc il y avait à la fois un dispositif
qui n'était pas sans rappeler
effectivement une forme d'opération
spéciale c'est un truc un peu light et
en même temps des objectifs politiques
qui eux semblait extrêmement élevé
c'est-à-dire que alors probable
probablement que va dire Poutine ne
souhaitait pas annexer l'intégralité de
l'Ukraine pour plein de raisons il
aurait pas pu la tenir etc mais dès le
début on peut imaginer que les buts de
guerre russes étaient d'abord de faire
tomber le régime de ski ce qui voulait
dire quand même réussi à une au moins
une grosse opération commando à Kiev et
puis par ailleurs il semblerait que là
on le voit aujourd'hui que que
l'objectif reux à la fin c'est quand
même de se saisir définitivement d'une
partie du sud et de l'est de l'Ukraine
et grosso modo on sait pas jusqu'où mais
c'est une part tout ou partie de
l'ancienne nous nous nosorussia la
nouvelle Russie qui était le cette
province de l'Empire russe dans le sud
de l'Ukraine qui correspond au
territoire que les Russes avaient pris à
l'Empire ottoman à la fin du XVIIIe mais
tout au long du XIXe siècle et ça semble
ça le l'objectif après les buts de
guerre
dépendent toujours de la conduite de la
guerre parce que quand la guerre se
passe mal vous êtes obligé de changer de
changer vos buts et vice-versa donc
maintenant jusqu'où les liens Poutine
peut-il aller on l'a on voit très bien
qu'il a peu de marge de manœuvre en
réalité aujourd'hui s'il arrive à
consolider déjà obtenir et à consolider
ces quatre blagues ça paraît énorme
étant donné que ce sont les
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui qui sont à
l'offensive et qui ont l'initiative qui
qui sont initiatives comme on disait
alors sur le site de stockage Vegas nous
dit que c'est le site Duke Dink alors
c'est en Lettonie du coup c'est
compliqué à dire une cul calls 4,5
milliards en mètres cubes ancien site de
stockage stratégique alimentant
voilà je vous crois
on fera des recherches pour vérifier
tout ça bien évidemment mais voilà merci
en tout cas pour cette information il y
avait une petite question que je voulais
aussi vous poser sur cette sur ce qui
arrive la nuit est-ce que ça peut donner
des idées à d'autres on a Machiavel qui
nous parle des tensions en Arménie en
Géorgie est-ce que ça la faiblesse russe
pourrait relancer
bien sûr c'est comme ça c'est ce qu'on a
vu tous ces toutes ces dernières
semaines avec la réactivation peut plus
ou moins
forte pas forcément
des escalade complète mais on a vu des
conflits larvés réapparaît entre
l'Ouzbékistan et les
Tadjikistan entre l'Arménie et et le
laserbaïdjan je vais y arriver et voilà
et en fait ce dont on rencontre si vous
voulez c'est que la Russie
traditionnellement c'est un peu le le
parrain de la région qui qui veut dire
garantit un certain ordre
issus de la décomposition de l'Union
soviétique et bien là c'est très simple
en Arménie par exemple quand il y a eu
la guerre il y a non pas l'été dernier
mais celui d'avant au carambar entre
l'Arménie et les airbags
bien finalement la Russie à la Russie a
réussi à obtenir un cessez le feu et
pour ça envoyer on va dire des
missions russe de maintien de la paix
avec quelques camions des chars etc mais
aujourd'hui toutes les toutes l'énergie
russe c'est absorber par l'Ukraine et
par ailleurs on se rend compte à quel
point
la Russie n'est pas la puissance
militaire qu'on pouvait croire et donc
ça évidemment ça fragilise
toute cette zone du monde qui en plus
c'est est au carrefour entre le on va
dire l'influence russe historique
l'influence de certains états comme la
Turquie et là aussi ça remonte à loin
puisque avant il y avait le l'Empire
ottoman et puis par ailleurs c'est une
zone l'Asie centrale qui est qui est
aussi le lien direct avec l'Asie là où
il y a la croissance et donc avec la
Chine etc etc donc lui c'est une zone un
peu Bou et on l'a vu ces trois ces trois
derniers jours il y avait l'ambassadeur
l'ambassadeur Gérard arrow qui avait une
très belle une très bonne formule pour
résumer tout ça il parlait d'une guerre
de succession de l'Union soviétique je
pense qu'on peut pas alors c'est une
guerre qui est pas complètement chaude
en tout cas à tous les endroits mais
mais mais très clairement c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit et c'est pas terminé il y
aura le problème un jour ou l'autre de
la Biélorussie il faut espérer qu'il n'y
ait jamais de problème dans les Pays-Bas
tout le savez qu'il y a aussi des
populations russophone mais pour le coup
les balles sont partis sont protégées
par le temps puisqu'ils en font partie
voilà il y a plein de conflits
potentiels qui sont plus ou moins
énervé qui pourrait ressortir maquiller
avec une guide le but de Poutine serait
de se réparti maintenant de viabiliser
la Crimée avec une connexion une
continuité terrestre jusqu'à Sébastopol
oui bah c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est le
c'est l'objectif à mon avis minimum
minimal pour que les pour que Poutine ne
partent pas la face c'est à dire que si
il arrive
à dire aux Russes bon écoutez il y a une
guerre on n'a pas été très brillant on a
eu quelques difficultés mais regardez le
résultat on a obtenu au total quasiment
130 000 km² c'est un pays comme la Grèce
et surtout on a désormais une continuité
territoriale entre la Crimée et le
territoire russe et puis on a un pied
sur le Nieppe qui permet de garantir
l'eau
l'accès en eau à la Crimée
c'est clairement un objectif suffisant
pas forcément le meilleur résultat qu'il
souhaiterait mais un résultat suffisant
à partir duquel le Kremlin serait
d'accord pour commencer des négociations
ça je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire ça le problème c'est
que les Ukrainiens ne le veulent pas et
les succès militaires de ces dernières
semaines leur font dire que eux non
seulement ils peuvent reprendre le don
base apeurait déjà Carson mais peut-être
même et donc un des points qui sera
intéressant à voir c'est le soutien
américain
jusqu'où le la position américaine et la
position
ukrainienne ce superposant
même si les Occidentaux reconnaîtront
jamais une crimérus mais de là à ne pas
si vous voulez entre ne pas reconnaître
et appuyer une offensive ukrainienne en
Crimée il y a clairement une sacrée
distance
surtout euh combiné à la question de la
dissuasion nucléaire et de l'usage de
l'armement du client tactique on a que
spot qui nous ont justement jusqu'où
iront les Ukrainiens en cas de défaite
des Russes ça dépend ce qu'on parle en
tant que défaite de russe effectivement
on ne sait pas très franchement on ne
peut pas exclure parce que je vous
disais l'effet les 300000 réservistes
russes on les verra pas d'ici on va dire
1 mois donc les les Ukrainiens ont
potentiellement un mois pour avancer on
ne peut pas exclure que vous voyez à
coup puissance je vous disais tout à
l'heure ou à Liman
il y a une percée et un effondrement
localisé russe alors ils vont pas tout
reprendre mais mais on peut imaginer une
nouvelle percée Akerson pour l'instant
les Russes tiennent mais combien de
temps là encore on ne sait pas et il y a
énormément de rumeurs de de potentiels
offensive
ukrainienne à zapuridja c'est-à-dire
la zone du milieu si vous voulez
tout est possible ce qui est certain
c'est les Ukrainiens ont l'initiative
qu'ils ont un avantage numérique que ils
ont moins d'armements en quantité mais
que c'est compensé par des armements
occidentaux qui sont des armements de
poing ce qu'ils ont d'excellentes
qualités tactiques qu'ils ont le
renseignement américain qui change
absolument la donne de manière décisive
et voilà donc
trop difficile de répondre à cette
question mais mais on a quelques idées
voilà on a quelques clés minot qui nous
demande est-ce que la Biélorussie est
active militairement dans ce conflit non
papa directement et même on se souvient
quand les Russes étaient passées par la
biologie l'acte 1 de la guerre où il y
avait un front au nord et qui venait
directement de la Biélorussie il y avait
pas de soldat biélorus et pour une
raison assez simple c'est qu'il y a eu
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
le cash and Co le président dictateur
biélorusses a été rééluia il y a deux
ans dans des conditions pour le moins
difficile il y avait eu des
manifestations
extrêmement
importantes dans toute la Biélorussie
donc c'est un régime extrêmement fragile
il avait été soutenu pas alors qui qui
n'a tenu grosso modo que parce qu'il est
allé voir il s'est mis dans les mains de
Moscou alors qu'elles vont y jouer un
jeu d'équilibriste entre l'Occident et
la Russie donc maintenant il est pieds
liés à Poutine mais en revanche si s'il
y avait une mobilisation biélorusse les
il y aura un risque énorme de de de
mobilisation civile enfin de
contestation interne en Biélorussie et
je suis pas sûr que lukajenko est
Poutine ait envie de ça en ce moment
alors on a quelques questions sur la sur
l'avenir de Vladimir Poutine aussi on va
en parler je vais juste vous montrer ces
deux articles qui sont très intéressants
alors hop le premier c'est celui là coup
d'État attentat des institution de la
lumière Poutine est-il en danger et le
deuxième vous pouvez le retrouver dans
le sur la sur le dans le journal du
Figaro d'aujourd'hui en Russie la
mobilisation finira-t-elle en révolte
contre Poutine écrit par leur Mondeville
c'est une question qui se pose cette
mobilisation elle peut fragiliser
Poutine intérieurement est-ce que on
peut aller jusqu'à une destitution
jusqu'à un renversement du pouvoir par
les Russes je pense que pour l'instant
on n'en est pas là clairement pas je
dirais qu'il faut avoir une
chose à l'esprit c'est que si jamais
Vladimir Poutine était
destitué d'une manière ou d'une autre ça
ne signifie pas qu'on aurait à la place
au Kremlin
un enfant de cœur
libéral pro-démocrate et ce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs de manière assez intéressante
en Russie c'est que il y a la droite de
Poutine énormément une part importante
de la
peut-être pas de la population peut-être
de la population mais en tout cas des
sphères d'influence qui qui considèrent
que Poutine est à la main trop trop
fébrile qui aurait dû depuis longtemps
sonner la mobilisation en général qu'il
aurait dû frapper de manière beaucoup
plus forte et importante les
infrastructures
ukrainiennes les couper l'électricité en
Ukraine etc donc oui il pourrait on
pourrait imaginer un remplacement un
Poutine qui serait beaucoup plus
nationaliste il faut bien penser que
Poutine est arrivé au pouvoir il y a 30
ans maintenant
on critiquant un Boré celle-ci qui était
jugé trop mou trop vieux trop trop
faible face aux Occidentaux
évidemment il faudrait pas que possible
se retrouve dans cette position là ce
n'est pas encore le cas mais la manière
dont on va se passer la mobilisation va
être va être absolument décisive
effectivement alors on a Griffit ce qui
nous parle d'un sujet qu'on a qu'on a
abordé tout à l'heure sur les référendum
il me dit peut-on envisager que les
résultats du référendum d'annexion soit
faussée par le Kremlin car les chiffres
paraissent énormes qui voudraient faire
serment d'ailleurs à son envahisseur
parce que je suis obligé de cette
question de oui enfin vous pouvez
choisir ça ça fait quand même beaucoup
penser
au bon vieux score soviétique
de 98 97% quand même c'est quand même
beaucoup voilà c'est effectivement assez
impressionnant comme score puis vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure aussi
comment on fait des référendums alors
qu'on contrôle pas tout un noblesse
absolument c'est qu'on ne connaît même
pas exactement l'étendue de voilà quel
est le corps électoral
les gens ont voté parfois chez eux
sous escort militaires enfin c'est un
peu il y a des gens qui venaient avec
des avec des gardes au début il y a un
article dans le journal du jour écrit
par Alain barlouet qui raconte ça on a
des on a des gens qui qui on avait des
bureaux de vote dans des voitures ils en
avaient déjà vu mais là il y a des gens
qui ont fait voter avec des soldats qui
viennent chez vous pour vous demander ce
que vous voulez voter il y a des
garanties qui de manière évidente ne
sont pas là mais
mais voilà c'est évident on a une autre
question sur les possibles négociations
tant que actuellement tant que les
Ukrainiens continuent d'avancer
il n'y a pas de négociation possible non
pour l'instant c'est pour l'instant
c'est pas possible parce que si vous
voulez le la les Russes ou abattu une
carte politique on va dire avec ces
référendum ils ont abattu une carte
militaire avec la mobilisation
et les Ukrainiens ont un cas d'intérêt à
négocier parce que pour l'instant ils
sont ils ont l'initiative militaire
maintenant c'est c'est une fois qu'on
aura vu cette confrontation entre cette
nouvelle donne parce que malgré tout
c'est quand même différent il y a
quelques semaines
c'est après coup qu'on pourra se dire
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a atteint le
point culbine culminant de la guerre
vous savez ça fait longtemps qu'on dit
qu'on allait atteindre le point
culminant de la guerre c'est une
expression que la haute vie de Sienne
déjà le point à partir duquel ça se
stabilise parce qu'il y a plus d'énergie
et ce qu'on fait c'est stabilisé pendant
plusieurs mois c'est vrai sauf que là
Miss début septembre il y a eu
l'offensive
ukrainienne avec toutes les réserves
qu'on a dites le fait que les Russes
sont repliés etc et malgré tout c'était
un grand changement
et puis là on pouvait se dire c'est de
nouveau un
point de
point culminant si les russes arrivent à
tenir leurs frontière mais on voit que
c'est pas certain et par ailleurs que
donnera la guerre non dans quelques mois
quand il y aura non plus de 100000 mais
peut-être
300400500000 soldats en Ukraine oui et
puis on parlait la dernière fois je me
rappelle on avait parlé du fait de ne
plus avoir de mission côté ukrainien
mais là ils en ont peut-être récupéré
grâce aux prises qu'ils ont fait alors
ça c'est sûr qu'ils ont récupéré des des
armes à carquises
c'est important ça paraît pas non plus
astronomique ce qui d'ailleurs tente à
montrer que les Russes se sont bien
repli en bonne ordre voilà mais c'est
sûr que ça leur fait énormément
du côté russe il y a eu vraiment des
pertes de matériel depuis le 24 février
qui sont considérables on parle de plus
de
nettement plus de 1000 chars d'assaut
les Français ils ont nous on a 200 char
d'assaut c'est les chars Leclerc donc
c'est comme si on avait perdu 5 fois et
cinq fois c'est si c'est 1000 et donc
souvenir c'est beaucoup plus de 1000 si
c'est pas quasiment 2000 d'accord je
redonnerai les chiffres la prochaine
fois donc vous voyez c'est
voilà après quand il y a une
mobilisation militaire il y a toujours
une mobilisation économique donc est-ce
que les médiations économiques au sens
où toutes les forces du pays sont mis
dans la conduite de la guerre pour créer
des munitions etc ce que les Russes vont
y arriver encore une fois on verra on le
verra et on aura la réponse plus tard on
vous invitera pour avoir
des points merci en tout cas d'avoir été
très nombreux à nous suivre merci
beaucoup Alexis d'avoir et à bientôt
avec nous pour en parler je salue aussi
Robin Nito qui était avec nous à la
modération que vous a transmis certaines
de vos questions et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux live sur figa
live